how are you doing these days andy you're
getting through yeah yeah yeah i just
you know
i just sit here and uh they turn off the
lights when they're done and then when
they come back in they turn them back
up and i'm still here yeah well you know
what we're doing lately is putting a
sheet over you at night
so dust doesn't collect on your fork i
know it's it's very appreciated
yeah and i uh i'm ready for halloween
i'm a ghost that's right halloween in
two days what are you seriously are you
gonna go out on halloween
no there's a pandemic oh yeah but you
wear a mask
i'm in this i'm going to open like a the
a little slot in my door and just throw
candy at people as they walk by that's a
good idea for my fortress
i want to get a high-powered air rifle
that fires hard candies at people
and i just want to fire candies at
people and hit him hard
right a snickers sling shot yeah
something that fires candy
150 miles an hour you see like a twix
bar ricochet off someone's
right yeah i just hit him with a twix
bar at 600 yards
yeah somebody 30 years from now what's
that lump in your neck a baby ruth
[Laughter]
couldn't remove it yeah close to the
spine
well you know we got to talk about
halloween but also you can't escape it
covid you know we got to talk about it
it's in the news like many states
california where we tape this show is
experiencing a spike
in coronavirus cases and this has caused
some people to quarantine inside their
homes
again now at the same time other people
in la are still shopping and dining out
at restaurants and gathering with
friends and family
and it's hard to say what the right move
is people are conflicted
so i figured the easiest way to tell how
things are
in los angeles right now is the
old-fashioned way
what if i just took a look outside and
judged for myself what do you think andy
just go and take a look
i think it's brave of you brave but also
very brave you know i'm gonna do this
right now i'm gonna take a uh quick look
outside let's see for ourselves what's
going on in l.a i think people are
making too big a deal out of this
you know fortunately we're right here in
west hollywood
so i'll get about as good of you as you
can get
[Music]
maybe we stay in on halloween andy yeah
yeah yeah
i think that's probably the way to go
staying in is
uh the new going out staying in is the
new going out
yes
no sense foolish